a basic Academy student is suing CCSD
for failing to protect him from bullying
and his lawyer says he gets multiple
inquiries from students looking to sue
bullies every week
they're not taking these cases seriously
if they were
they would be not just settling but
changing their policy you have a school
district who who takes the approach of
hey here's our maximum
we're we're protected by the legislature
that we don't have to pay above a
hundred thousand dollars so what do we
care that's our worst day in court it
progressed into in the suit 17 year old
Nicholas Monroe alleges three other
students beat him he's asking the
parents of each student to pay ten
thousand dollars each for medical
expenses and psychological distress the
trial is scheduled for September